[Musique]
je pense à dole fihri je pense à nos
vingt ans c'est mais pas beaucoup et
pourtant rester ensemble dès qu'on se
croise et depuis toujours c'était comme
ça ils sont tous là à parler morts
bernard arrête
oui bien sûr qui peut être là le crous
et tétouan
[Musique]
toujours été comme ça une famille de fou
ça quand elle nous a même pas présenter
sa femme il était tellement jeune vous
feriez rigide
tu ferais quoi si on t'empêcher de reuil
tu ferais quoi si on occupe depuis on se
bat pour la france il est comme il est
mais l'a toujours été gentil avec moi je
t'ai écrit tout ça l'ennuie des corvées
ceux qui buvaient jusqu'à ce qu'ils
s'écroulent les tours de garde le soleil
qui tournait la seule la poussière mais
le reste non lé réseau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas des hommes qui font des trucs
pareils sont des chiens
c'est un peu pâle raconter parce qu'il
n'y a pas de mots pour raconter ça
[Musique]
y'a pas mort on peut pas le dire
pour même pas imaginer
[Musique]
des hommes des hommes avaient fait
simple
[Musique]